The Joe Rogan Experience because my
uncles the paganas the Italian twins
they did Marilyn Monroe they did all the
movie stars so when I was a little kid I
was in their beauty shop wow and I got
this was the first time you saw a movie
star how old oh three
so it wasn't even weird to you no
and then I did it their hair see I dried
you're you know on the magazine thing
clients come
they tell their friends
I was doing 30 40 people a day so how
did you go from was it Barbra
Streisand's hand you went from here it
was basically Barbara yeah I met her I
put the word out that I wanted to meet
her and I'd go anywhere Anytime Anyplace
for free and I knew the free would get
her and Charles are you a hustler yeah
baby I am a [ __ ] every sense of
the goddamn word crazy question what a
crazy question to ask someone such a
strange question I don't know it was
Dana White Hustler are you a hospital
okay so you hustle right yeah even when
your leg hurts Joshua me too the only
difference is that I had to deal with
overwhelming anxiety which I have now
pretty much got under control what start
well that's another thing just just
going into the fight because everything
was like a fight to me right so you were
constantly yeah so when I was a kid and
we were Van Nuys junior high school and
one of the Chicanos telling me off we'd
I'd meet them in the back of the gym 500
kids would show up and we'd go at it I
take them out I'd wrestle them down boom
wrap up it was it really and it happened
30 times people would challenge me the
kids would come and I always had a sense
of dramatic you know one time I knew I
couldn't beat this kid there was the
bleachers he was standing there I went
up on the beat bleachers and I did a
Superman punch I dove off the beaches
and hit him like that and knocked them
out you know really I went this way that
way and he went out yeah
I didn't know it was a Superman punch I
used the bleachers as a as a launching
pad for my punch
that's a creative maneuver yeah I'm a
creative guy I get it
I never gotten any street fights like
that yeah I avoided them all one time
yeah I was smart but yeah my dad died I
get it I didn't feel the punches I
didn't feel nothing yeah I got shot
right now I chest I didn't feel it you
got shot in your chest yeah what caliber
22. oh so it stayed why did somebody
shoot you yeah it was a gang fighting
guy brought a couple of guns and this
guy shot the gun and it will hit me in
the chest and then like many years later
when I married Leslie and Warren who was
a big Broadway star we went to the
doctor and the guy took me in the room
he said so what is it you know you got a
bullet in your chest I said don't tell
anybody who was in the fatty part of the
thing and it's still there right now I
love doing hair how did you get into
hairdressing when I got out of juvie uh
my mother uh the judge said you have to
put him somewhere so she put me in
Beauty School
yeah
how'd you shoot it yeah
um it was an ax I never said this before
five people by accident yeah well no it
was a gang fight it was a fight in this
in San Fernando and it was like 30 guys
and uh
uh has a statute of limitations passed
on this or should we edit this out yes
yes and and and and it was uh somebody
else's
everybody in wood shop was making a
weapon
I remember that from high school yeah I
used to make nunchucks and yeah yes yes
exactly yeah yeah that's what happened
and these this guy came with these guns
and
these guys was when I bang bang and then
this guy was it was it and then I was
like oh my God what the [ __ ] that was
the changing of my life that and when I
was in juvie a guy that I met from Boys
Town which was a a in the middle of the
country a place where a lot of [ __ ] up
kids would go he came from Boys Town he
ran away he went to juvie and they they
weren't supposed to they weren't
supposed to have thing and they covered
it up but he tried to get away and they
shot him on the fence right in front of
me and 30 other guys
and uh and uh he was uh [ __ ] you he was
I said man you're gonna get killed you
got to shut your [ __ ] mouth you gotta
take it cool if you're gonna get out of
here you got to work you're out there's
no escaping us
strong the blonde haired guy Farmer Boy
years ago and then I'm getting tired I
gotta go but
years ago when I was with Leslie on
Warren I was at a beauty shop and it was
on the corner of rodeo and Brighton way
it was called the John Peter Salon
OJ would come hunt the girls everybody's
hunt the girls because I'd have like 40
or 50 beautiful girls getting their hair
done all day long
this guy comes in my mother happened to
be working at the desk and he comes in
big overalls big tall guy and he
um says I'm here to see uh Cinderella
you know Leslie unworn and I I came out
of my husband and he was like a fan of
Mission Impossible whatever it was I
don't remember with the time next thing
I know we went home that night and he
had been there in the colony he had come
to the Colony so I sent out a bunch of
my guys because a lot of the
hairdressers I had were guys like you
there were tough kids that were smart
and they were and they and they needed a
chance they went to beauty school they
got out and they women were lined up
around the block sounds like a movie it
is my life is like a crazy that does
sound like a movie a bunch of tough guy
hairdressers yes out there protecting
you right out in front with all the
motorcycles all lined up wow so tough
guy hairdressers on motorcycles yes
that's a movie and the the when the
thing was over the LA Times said they
don't make hairdressers like they used
to because the guy Kate was coming into
the house he had a little pistol in his
hand like this he was walking in I had a
mezzanine I looked at him I was naked I
jumped on them as any Optimist and he
jumped on him he went through he jumped
on him with his pistol oh yeah I dove
right on I didn't see it until I was in
the air oh Jesus and he was like this
and it was dark and it was he was
backlit and you're naked and I was naked
yeah I was just I woke up I could hear
him walking around I wasn't thinking I
just moved that's a surprise
naked dude jumps on you from a mezzanine
and he hadn't ended up with 160 stitches
because he came to Robbie came to kidnap
her Jesus Christ so we fought out into
the into the colony naked me naked and
him in the former outfit yeah
hey good thing I didn't go to Heartland
right now oh my God good thing you'd
have questions well it's a true story I
believe it you'd look it up in the LA
Times